the SCP Foundation has dealt with its
fair share of superheroes from the
delightful scp-2800 the prickly Scottish
vigilante known as cactus man to the
utterly tragic
scp-2241 also known as the superhero
wannabe but we couldn't help but wonder
what if the SCP Foundation went up
against a truly evil anomalous force
that simply masqueraded as a superhero
and we can think of a character who fits
this bill better than homelander from
the boys the hit TV series produced by
our arch nemesis at Amazon homelander is
rotten to the core and has a wide range
of superpowers that allow him to make
his darkest desires a reality and that's
why today we're powering up the
animatron 6000 filling it with all three
current seasons of the boys and posing
the big question could the SCP
Foundation bring this sadistic soup to
his knees or is he just too
diabolical let's find out people love
superheroes they love that warm cozy
feeling that soups give them a golden
Beacon of righteousness to swoop out of
the sky and save the day so we don't
have to do it ourselves but you see the
thing about superheroes is they aren't
always nice if the whole world holds
someone up on a pedestal makes them
believe from a young age that they can
do no wrong that they're the ultimate
Paragon of virtue and that they have the
powers and freedom to do anything they
want while you end up with him the
homelander now some look too homelander
as a hero and why wouldn't they he flies
around saving people wearing those
distinctive stars and stripes on his
back and stars in all those movies about
how great he is but that's just a cover
story The publicly acceptable story put
out by VOD the company responsible for
creating him in the first place they are
there to sweep under the rug any bad
thing that homelander or any of their
so-called superheroes has ever done so
that nobody will ever figure out the
truth and what is the truth well as far
as soups go homelanders even worse than
the very worst of the worst he's a
murderous self-absorbed narcissistic
psychopath with no empathy for powerless
human beings he thinks of himself as
superior to the rest of us ordinary
people are just Expendable and it'll
gladly allow an entire Plane full of
innocent civilians to die with little
care or remorse oh but homelander will
play all that up for the cameras though
which is why nobody would ever think to
question his status as a hero as far as
the public knows homelanders actions are
always Justified and that he can do no
wrong and it's this mentality that
allows him to carry on doing whatever he
wants with total impunity but what if
everyone turned on homelander say his
cover was finally blown and the rest of
the world got to see him as he really is
a murderer with too much power rampant
insecurity an explosive temper and some
nasty lingering parental issues sure
getting a look at the real homelander
might be a cause for celebration from
his most hardcore Fanboys allowing them
to Rally behind what they think he
stands for but what if we all had enough
what if everybody rejected homelander as
it turns out that might be the final
straw that breaks him by his own
admission homelander would much prefer
to be loved by everyone but if you take
that away he's more than happy to settle
for being feared and with the level of
power that he has flight super strength
invulnerability heat vision all it would
take would be a show of his abilities in
order to incite fear and now it's
happened the love anyone had for
homelander is gone maybe his crimes have
finally been exposed or we might have
laser vision someone in broad daylight
regardless of the spark that started it
the fire has started burning and now
he's no longer chained homelander is
free to do whatever he wants he started
tactically taking out key structures of
influence in the United States the White
House went first the red hot beans of
his laser eyes carving through the
entire building separating staff and
secret service members at the waist or
the neck splattering the walls with
blood the quote world's greatest
superhero took care of the president
personally melting him down with his
heat vision before flying away next on
his list of targets was the Pentagon
shrugging off bullets and tank shells
from the United States military as they
were rapidly deploying to stop him it
didn't take long for homelander to cut
through the Soldier's scent to stop him
before demolishing the Pentagon with as
little as a supersonic clap of his hands
as the building crumbled around him so
did a number of the country's defenses
fall as well but there was one last line
of defense one organization that just
might have access to the means to bring
the only man in the sky back down to
ground level the SCP Foundation were no
strangers to powerful beings running
amok but they were the only ones with
the means to oppose a rampage like this
now while homelander had already
decimated much of the regular armed
forces the foundation brought an army of
their own to Bear enter the mobile task
forces the organization's most elite
special operatives they're specifically
trained to deal with threats well beyond
the capabilities of the regular military
and can be quickly deployed almost
anywhere in the world at a moment's
notice ready for action mobilizing their
collected forces the foundation
dispatched its mtfs at once they had to
be smart homelander was playing this
tactically taking out centers of
influence and defense capabilities still
unleashing his years worth of bottled up
rage but using it in a controlled
calculated way if they sent every mobile
task force to where homelander was he
could easily fly away at supersonic
speeds outmaneuver them or just
disintegrate foundation's entire reserve
of troops in one move so their primary
goal was to divide and conquer and
spread their mtfs across the country so
that anywhere homelander went they would
be waiting for him of course the fall of
the regular military had already shown
that Conventional Weapons had little to
no effect on homelander he is completely
resistant to almost every form of
physical harm not only completely
bulletproof but unfazed by explosions as
well on top of that his powers for
detecting threats were also unparalleled
homelander had the ability to see
through almost any solid object or
Surface using x-ray vision however the
foundation knew there was a limit to
this ability and that the soup couldn't
see through certain Metals specifically
zinc he also had tremendous olfactory
and auditory senses well beyond that of
any ordinary human being homelander
could detect changes and smell on such
an acute level that he could detect
changes to someone's adrenaline levels
as well as using that ability to detect
explosives but it was his super hearing
that the foundation was planning to
exploit they knew homelander senses were
so attuned he could detect changes in a
person's heartbeat enough to know when
someone was lying however having such a
high level of sensitive hearing meant
that homelander had at least one
vulnerability high frequency sound waves
the foundation knew it wouldn't be
enough to kill the man in the sky but
they had another trick up their sleeve
for that first they needed to draw him
out but how would they when homelander
could easily overhear the orders being
broadcast to their troops simple they
could buy the foundation started issuing
falsified directions to its mtfs on the
ground each one followed up with a
written digital message via each troop's
heads-up display all Foundation
operatives were reminded to disregard
any radio communications that these
weren't real orders merely just
interference to throw homelander off
what they were actually doing while the
fake radio orders were attempting to
nudge homelander closer and closer
towards New York which was where Vaught
Tower his headquarters were located one
team was already there lying in wait
mobile task force Pi one also known by
the code name City Slickers they had
received a coded message from the
foundation they were instructed to
infiltrate Vaught Tower retrieve an item
from the company's research and
development labs and then make their way
to the roof once they were there the
next stage of the plan was to administer
what they found in r d and await and
airdrop of high frequency Sonic Weaponry
that the foundation was sending to Aid
them storming vot Tower had been the
surprisingly easy part the entire
company had fallen into chaos now that
their number one product was reigning
depth from the sky the employees had
bought didn't seem to care much about
their jobs anymore the City Slickers had
snuck into the laboratory and found what
they were sent for temporary compound
five a chemical that would alter human
biology and Grant anyone's superpowers
for a 24-hour period it had the nasty
side effect of turning the user's brain
into swiss cheese but under the
circumstances it seemed necessary dosing
themselves with it all the City Slickers
were in agony as they felt the v24
burning in their veins just as the
chopper was arriving to drop off their
Weaponry a loud booming sound rang out
shattering Windows across the city as
homelanders approach broke the sound
barrier the MTF stared up in horror as
his laser vision cut through the
helicopter above their heads one of the
crates landing on the roof as the fiery
wreck plummeted down towards the street
Jackson the team leader yelled to one of
his men before pausing he knew that if
he he told him to retrieve the Sonic
Cannon homelander would destroy it in
seconds instead Jackson watched as his
commanding officer leaped up into the
air hundreds of feet higher than he
would normally have been capable of he
careened towards a surprised homelander
swinging a compound v-fueled uppercut
that connected with his jaw reeling him
slightly as he hovered above taking that
as their cue the other members of the
city slicker started attacking the
out-of-control soup one of them was
firing energy blasts from his palms and
another had her arms stretching out like
rubber grabbing homelander's cape in an
attempt to drag him out of the sky
meanwhile Jackson was scrambling across
the roof of the tower fumbling with the
clasps on the crate that contained the
weapon he could hear snarling behind him
as homelander roared in disapproval
disgusted that these so-called ordinary
people were daring to attack him his
heat vision burned through the City
Slickers uniforms but couldn't Pierce
their skin enraged homelander gripped
the Commander's head as he made another
jump towards him pushing both his super
strong hands together until he could
hear the man's skull beginning to crack
then he kept squeezing flattening the
commander between his palms homelander
flew downwards Landing a dual fisted
punch that burst through the chests of
the other two Slickers he pulled both
hands back his red gloves like the rest
of his uniform already slickened with
copious amounts of blood then a loud
shrieking sound pierced his attuned ears
as Jackson fired the Sonic Cannon the
cacophony of high frequency sound waves
it emitted were deafening to homelanders
attuned sensitive ears sending pain
shooting through his head unfortunately
pain meant little to homelander and he
could still function despite it it
angered him even further that someone
was trying to best him that they'd
highlighted and tried to exploit a
weakness something the soup had told
himself he didn't have he shot forwards
Lightning Fast wrenching the device out
of Jackson's hands before gripping him
by the throat lifting him up off his
feet so that he was dangling over the
edge of the tower who in the hell do you
think you are homelander muttered
disturbingly subdued despite the obvious
unhinged look in his eyes just just
Jackson gasp for breath as he felt
fingers clasping around his fault in the
distance there was a low rhythmic
rumbling like an earthquake or heavy
footsteps getting closer just a
distraction with that homelander's hand
closed tight the very second that
Jackson teleported out of his grip
leaving the soup standing on the roof
alone save for the bodies of the other
City Slickers he turned to face the
sound of the oncoming footsteps
detecting the sound of wearing Machinery
along with it this was something new it
was rare for homelander to ever face a
real challenge nothing ever forced him
to improve his skills in combat in most
cases he could just rely on his strength
or bring a quick end to confrontations
with his eye lasers which made the side
of
scp-5514 approaching all the more
surprising to him striding across the
city like something out of a Pacific Rim
movie was a gigantic Mac known as
scp-5514 or by its far cooler sounding
nickname the dragon slayer working with
the global occult Coalition and high
Brazil the foundation themselves
constructed
scp-5514 using various anomalous methods
designing the machine to combat
large-scale aggressors or lsas while the
dragon slayer like the name implies was
built with fighting monsters and Kaiju
similar to its own size these desperate
times had called for desperate measures
the next huge robotic arm hosted its
primary weapon a cold iron sword its
blade 20 meters long inside mobile task
force Ada 5 the Jaeger bombers were
piloting the dragon slayer readying for
battle with homelander he was staying
still not attempting to run or even Fly
Away instead he stayed at the top of VOD
Tower it was like he was waiting
watching unfazed by the approaching
humanoid machine looking right at it or
through it the dragon slayer brought its
cold iron swords swooping down through
the the air the blade coming right down
on where homelanders stood it cleaved
directly through the building beneath
him carving Vaught Tower in two sending
a shower of glass and concrete over the
plaza below the suit caught the blade as
it came at him screaming in pain as he
felt it cut into his hands any wound
left by the cold iron sword was
permanent there was no regeneration or
recovering from it homelander's natural
durability gave him an edge that and
being so much smaller than the sword
itself allowed him not to be sliced to
Pieces but even touching it through his
gloves hurt the tower was Rubble
homelander was down but far from out he
climbed up through the debris and bodies
he was buried under not caring when he
blasted his heat vision through the dead
and wounded to clear a path back up
looming above the dragon slayer stood
taller than most buildings his eyes
glowing both with anger and the red
light of his lasers homelander pushed
himself up off the ground and flew up
into the air the mech's arm moved
weightlessly to swat him out of the air
but homelander used his speed and
momentum to shoot through the metal
ripping through the machine's hand
before it could land a strike homelander
started zipping out of the path of the
Dragon Slayer as it opened fire with its
various anomalous armaments while the
Mac was primarily used for Close
Quarters melee combat with various lsas
it also featured a number of longer
range Weaponry mounted on
scp-5514 shoulder was a Beowulf sigured
railgun an anomalous weapon that could
use altered gravity to affect the weight
of its targets causing projectiles to
impact with higher velocity yet none of
these projectiles landed a shot unable
to catch homelander at his current
flight speed with every supersonic pass
he made of the Dragon Slayer the
deranged soup took another look at his
current enemy his X-ray eyes could
penetrate most of the metal and gave him
a clear enough view of what was inside
there was a miniature Sun powering it
kept perpetually stable while it
generated energy for
scp-5514 surrounding it were
sub-dimensional portals venting the
excess heat off this plane of reality so
that the mech and nothing around it
melted a similar process was moving some
of the substantial weight of the mech
into a tiny pocket Dimension which had
allowed it to move so swiftly without
being too cumbersome piloting it were
humans more MTF operatives spotting them
through the metal Hull homelander flew
towards the dragon slayer like a bullet
the force of the impact caused the mech
to wobble slightly as homelanders shot
through the outer layers of armor he
came bursting out into the main chamber
eyes burning intense lasers through the
vital inner components of the Dragon
Slayer the beam sliced the unprotected
mtfs up reducing them to a bloody Pace
before homelander turned his rage
towards the power source ripping through
more of the metal work he looked at the
housing for the sub-dimensional portals
venting out of the mini Sun's heat
though he had a limited understanding of
what exactly this all was homelander
could make sense of what it was doing he
fired off another series of blasts with
his heat beams tearing through the
devices that regulated the portals
before flying back out of the Dragon
Slayer as fast as he could landing at
its feet he looked up to see his
despicable handiwork from within the
subdimensional portals began pulling the
insides of scp-5514 in different
directions pulling it apart and sucking
it into different pocket Dimensions as
it collapsed in on itself homelander's
side the tiniest hint of fatigue he felt
passing in a fleeting moment gone before
the dragon slayer eventually fell enough
cease this villainy a voice called from
nearby homelander sighed in exasperation
to face this latest nuisance that dare
to pose him when he saw the shadowy
figure approaching him he was taken
aback at first thinking he recognized
who it was
Noir he asked in disbelief no that is
not my name the Dark Cloud figure
announced homelander of the seven your
time has come for now you face the
Specter otherwise known as
scp-4494 was the physical embodiment of
crime fighting itself its long dark
cloak whipped in the wind a wide-rimmed
hat pulled low giving it the appearance
of a shadowy gunslinger from head to toe
the Specter seemed to pull all light on
the visible spectrum into itself making
it look like a ghostly Shadow come to
life and how the hell do they expect you
to stop me homelander sneered I go
wherever Injustice Reigns The Specter
replied not short on dramatic Flair and
you have Unleashed horrific unspeakable
Terror on the innocence of this world I
will ask you once and once only stop
this walk away immediately homelander
started laughing
[Laughter]
really that's all you've got he's
scoffed just asking nicely You've Lost
Your Way SCP
before declared all this destruction
meant for what just to display your
power to subjugate make people fear you
or are you still trying to win the
approval of a mother and father you
never had the last sentence struck a
nerve with homelander enough to make him
zip forward launching a punch at the
Specter his fist passed through a dark
fog that took the place of its intended
target as scp-4494 dissipated and then
reformed behind homelander it put two
shadowy arms around his neck ripping the
maddening soup in a headlock you were
made to be a hero the Specter whispered
look at how far you've Fallen homelander
angrily wrenched the arm away and threw
his captor over his head only forth the
Specter to become a Mist again
surrounding the hero in a thick black
cloud he fired his heat vision again the
beams passing through the lair of fog
without causing any damage it's over
homelander no longer will you terrorize
the innocent came a booming dramatic
voice from all angles you are not the
hero you think of yourself as but a
villain this mistake stops here this
isn't a mistake I don't make mistakes
homelander Ward I'm not like the rest of
you I'm stronger smart I'm better I am
better I'm the real hero are you Echo
The specter's Voice something thin and
papery landed at homelander's feet the
fog dissipating again as the Specter
stood before him confused homelander
picked up the papery object it was a
comic book The Words Action Comics
emblazoned on the top the cover showed a
man dressed much like himself lifting an
old green car above his head his red
cape billowing in the wind a letter s
worn across his chest as he flicked
through the pages tears formed in
homelander's eyes this is what you think
you are the Specter said solemnly but
look around look at the lives you've
taken or ruined a hero no heroism is not
subjugating others not View
self as Superior heroism is realizing we
are all the same and standing up to
those that would try to disagree the
Specter brought his dark cloak around
homelander's shoulder there were no
survivors around to see where they went
or to hear
scp-4494's final words you aren't a real
hero and then they were gone now if you
want to see another clash between a
comic book Legend and one of the most
infamously dangerous anomalies go and
check out Deadpool vs scp-682 to see the
Merc with the mouth battling the hard to
destroy reptile then after that if
you're in the mood for another chaotic
mash-up witness the Galaxy's greatest
Bounty Hunter taking on the flesh that
hates in Boba Fett vs scp-610